to put these potential firsts into
perspective we're joined by two people
who know a lot about political history
CBS News political contributor and
former Face the Nation moderator Bob
Schieffer who is covering his 25th
election and Pulitzer prize-winning
historian Doris Kearns Goodwin her new
book is called leadership in turbulent
times it's published by Simon & Schuster
a division of CBS good morning to you
both
Bob I want to start with you that clip
we showed of use in 1974 Nixon had
resigned forded pardoned him I mean a
lot was going on in the country people
think things are busy now put this
election in perspective as of all those
you've covered of all the ones that I've
covered I've never gone into one when I
was more unsure of what was going to
happen I mean I you know when you've got
what is it 40 races in the house now
that are not just too close to call
they're in the margin of error
nobody knows where those are going to go
this is going to be one election we'll
have to take the advice that people
always give us and that is we're going
to have to wait and see how people vote
because it's all going to be about
turnout it's all going to be about
turnout this Trump get out those people
that elected him president will that be
enough to give these Republicans a boost
or will that have a counter reaction you
know I think he's going to energize
Republicans but I think hearing these
things day after day I think he's also
going to energize Democrats what
happened many people say though Bob
indoors that this election will
determine who we are as a people who we
are as a country Barack Obama when he
was on the campaign trail said that this
is the most important election of our
time president Trump also said the same
thing do you both agree with that I do I
think it's a collective mirror on us who
we vote as our leaders where we are
going as a country what are our values
and the encouraging thing I think about
talking about young women coming into
office for the first time just at a time
when politics seems like a dishonorable
profession only 11 percent of the people
support the Congress these people want
to come in into it which is so exciting
and they're bringing something different
I think from the year of the women
before which may not have worked before
there are all sorts of emerge is working
to train them this
you've got more of an Emily's list
you've got an infrastructure and you've
got a feeling that somehow they're
Outsiders coming in to change the system
our system needs a revolution and I
think women can I swear my hope is
coming so doors talk about that because
you've just written this book on
leadership right 1984 was a year of the
woman because of the massive gender gap
1992 and result of the Clarence Thomas
hearings this year a different type of
year women because many of them are
actually gonna be on the ballot flooding
into Congress and state houses as well
how could that change how our country
operates what you know about leadership
well research shows that women tend to
cooperate more they've actually shown
and done these things that they tend to
be more moderate but I think most
importantly they're coming from being
doctors they're coming from being
lawyers they're coming from being
veterans they're teachers either - which
means they're coming yet something's
wrong with our system in Washington
right now it's like we've been in war
too long we don't know how to have peace
so you bring a fresh group of idealistic
people who still believe in government
we haven't even believed in government
in a long time right if they're coming
in and believing in it and they can
create a contagion among other people
Wow we did have a chance this is where
my hope goes president Trump has made
this he wants it to be a referendum on
him I mean he thinks most things are a
referendum on him but but that is beside
the point I think it is picking up on
what Doris just said I think it's a
referendum on us who we are what we
envision this country to be what is our
approach you know FDR said one time
something that I was always stuck with
me he said a nation does not have to be
cruel to be strong and I think that's
something that maybe pivotable pivotal
in how people vote and this is a point
Gael has been making this morning a big
race though in our home state of Texas
better or worse versus Ted Cruz but
interestingly enough you said your eyes
are gonna be focused on what happens in
Florida yeah I mean I think that
governor's race down there if the
Democrat pulls that off I think it will
ensure that bill and Nelson is
re-elected to the Senate I think at the
beginning of the year people thought it
would be the other way around
if he does that that might give us it'll
mean a big minority turnout a big black
vote turning out ID so I want to watch
that and see what happens and then if
you see the same thing happen in Georgia
in stacey abrams race down there you
might see a democratic blowout i'm not
sure that's going to happen but i think
that's a couple of things that i want to
watch Joris give us a little perspective
FDR lost almost 70 seats in 38 Truman
lost a whole mess in 46 Clinton in 94
Reagan in 86-82 these are all big losses
then they all went on their party or
they went on to get reelected right well
what happens in midterms usually is its
discontent that is motivating voters to
come to the poll you're angry with
whatever's happened interestingly it's
not usually the economy I mean in 1966
LBJ had six point six growth and yet
people were angry at him they're angry
at the war they were angry at the riots
so big losses for him in 1994 growth was
beginning to come back but Clinton had
stumbled around and they didn't like
what he was doing with three attorney
generals and the health care it failed
so he loses in 2010 the economy is
finally recovering which is really
interesting even though Obama loses big
my favorite one is in nineteen forty two
despite the economy coming back it's the
war full employment but coffee was
rationed three days before the election
only one cup a day it is that that Trump
is talking about discontent creating
discontent with a caravan to bring his
people to the polls also he says it's
just not exciting to talk about the
economy's portrayal for the economy is
what people's lives are like not
exciting more exciting to make up a
caravan he must be the first president
who was presiding over a good economy
who didn't want to talk about the
economy I'm still trying to figure that
one out and I don't know these you're
not the only one Bob Bob endure it's
great to have you on thank you it's
ready father it's nice